[Applaudissements]
quoi je suis avocat fiscaliste je
facture à l'heure alors j'ai l'habitude
de prendre mon temps
vous pensez que cette présentation
gratuite
vous m'offrez votre bien le plus
précieux le temps
et si vous m'en donnez un peu j'aimerais
vous montrer comment le temps pourrait
devenir un critère universel un critère
universel pour répartir les richesses
des multinationales de l'agroalimentaire
la richesse on peut la définir de
plusieurs manières les philosophes vous
parleront peut-être de famille d'amour
les médecins de santé et ils ont sans
doute raison
mais moi je suis avocat fiscaliste alors
je vais vous parler d'une autre richesse
l'argent
beaucoup d'argent des milliards de
dollars de bénéfices réalisés chaque
année dans le monde par les
multinationales
certains disent que le temps c'est de
l'argent alors comme avocat fiscaliste
je consacre une partie de mon temps à
m'intéresser aux impôts
n'ont pas les impôts que vous payez
ou que peut-être ne payez pas d'ailleurs
ne vous en faites pas
moi ce qui m'intéresse aujourd'hui ce
sont les impôts payés par les
multinationales de l'agroalimentaire
quand elle réalise des bénéfices c'est
un marché que certains estiment à 10
mille milliards de dollars chaque année
ce sont ces richesses que je vous
propose de partager avec le critère du
temps
avant d'y arriver il faut d'abord
comprendre comment une entreprise paye
ses impôts
quand une entreprise gagne de l'argent
elle doit en partager une partie avec le
pays dans lequel elles se trouvent
la situation est plutôt simple si
l'entreprise gagne de l'argent dans un
seul but
mais quand une société fait des
bénéfices dans plusieurs pays elle
devient une multinationale par exemple
en suisse il y à des multinationales qui
terrifie et vente du café
une partie de ce café est produit en
ethiopie je vous propose d'aller voir
sur place assise dame en scylla mot
c'est une région magnifique d'ethiopie
où youssouf produit du café pour une
multinationale suisse
youssouf part de chez lui à 5 heures du
matin pour se rendre au travail il
marche dans l'obscurité sur des routes
poussiéreuses pendant plus d'une heure
pour arriver dans un vaste champ
là il commence à tailler irriguées et
contrôler chacun des arbustes à café les
caféiers
ensuite il sélectionne les cerises à
café manuellement une à une il faudra
youssouf 14 heures de travail tous les
jours pendant dix mois pour pouvoir
enfin exporter son café vers la suisse
ici il faudra une vingtaine de minutes
and multi nationales pour l'auto rivier
et il me faudra quelques minutes de plus
pour le bois creux
dans cette situation
quel pays peut réclamer le paiement de
l'impôt l'ethiopie où la suisse qui doit
payer l'impôt le torréfacteur le
producteur le vendeur
ça se complique
pour répondre à ces questions il faut
revenir ici à genève en 1929 en 1929 où
les pays les plus riches se sont réunis
dans le cadre de la société des nations
l'ancêtre des nations unies
ils se sont demandés comment imposer le
bénéfice des multinationales
ils ont longuement réfléchi et après de
longues réflexions ils ont décidé que
l'argent devait aller chez eux
pour ça ils ont créé des conventions
fiscales ce sont des accords entre les
pays qui permettent de déterminer
comment on impose une entreprise qui
fait des bénéfices dans plusieurs pays
alors je vous résume un siècle
d'histoire et je vous propose de retenir
une chose les pays imposent leur
entreprise en fonction des prix du
marché le prix du marché c'est un prix
sur lequel un acheteur et un vendeur se
mettent d'accord par exemple moi quand
j'ai acheté ce qu'a fait je n'ai pas
vraiment osé négocier avec une
multinationale mais j'étais d'accord de
payer 4 francs
avec un kilo de café on peut faire
s'entassent et donc je vous passe le
petit calcul mais pour un kilo de café
le bénéfice de la miss nationale c'est
400 francs en réalité c'est un peu plus
compliqué la multinationale à des
dépenses elle doit payer ses employés
payer son café mais pour notre exemple
je vous propose de dire que la suisse
peut imposer la multinationale sur 400
francs
youssouf
lui il a essayé de négocier avec la
multinationale
ça ne va pas vraiment réussi
pour un kilo de café il a obtenu
un franc c'est le prix du marché
et donc les tubes qui veut imposer un
franc
les dix mois de travail de youssouf
n'ont aucune valeur face à la loi du
marché
cette vision a perduré plusieurs
décennies jusqu'en 2012
en 2012
ou cette petite tasse de café a provoqué
l'un des plus grands séismes de
l'histoire de la fiscalité
en 2012 un article nous a révélé que le
plus grand distributeur de café au monde
ne paient que 5 % d'impôt sur son
bénéfice
par la suite il ya eu d'autres
révélations et nous avons découvert que
de nombreuses multinationales et
chapelles en toute légalité au paiement
de leurs impôts
pourquoi eh bien les multinationales ont
tellement bien compris les règles du
marché qu'elles ont réussi à les
utiliser à leur profit pour payer moins
d'impôts
les vieilles méthodes de 1929 ne
fonctionne plus alors pour faire face à
cette situation
les états se sont à nouveau réunis dans
le cadre de l' ocde l'organisation de la
coopération et du développement
économiques
et cette fois ils ont osé l'impensable
ne plus tenir compte des règles du
marché
désormais on a une approche globale les
entreprises sont imposés au lieu de la
création de valeur la création de valeur
dans le cadre de mon métier je travaille
avec cette notion tous les jours
après avoir longuement étudié je vous
propose la définition suivante donnez
moi votre avis
chaque pays a un argument pour prétendre
que la création de valeur a lieu chez et
donc que l'imposition doit avoir lieu
chez lui les américains les européens
proposent le lieu de la consommation
puisqu'il ya beaucoup de consommateurs
chez eux les pays asiatiques nous
propose le lieu où il ya le plus
d'emploi puisqu'il ya beaucoup d'emplois
dans ces pays
la suisse a déjà essayé de proposer le
pays où les salaires sont le plus élevé
je vous laisse deviner pourquoi et bien
moi pour l'agriculture j'aimerais vous
proposer un critère neutre le temps
vous l'avez vu la valeur de ce café
dépend des dix mois de travail du
souffle et quelques minutes qu'il a
fallu à la multinationale pour l'auteur
y fier et peut-être du temps de ma
présentation pour le boire comment est
il possible d'ignorer tout le temps
passé en ethiopie pourtant dans
l'agriculture la confection d'un produit
dépend d'un travail réalisé sur le
produit et bien moi j'estime que les
tâches de youssouf et celle des employés
de la multinationale
la même valeur le temps passé par
youssouf et le temps passé par les
employés de la nhtsa nationale sont
équivalents le temps c'est le seul
critère face auquel tous les êtres
humains sont nécessairement ego
en choisissant le temps comme critère
chaque pays qui a consacré du temps à la
confection d'un produit bras droit à sa
juste part de valeur alors bien sûr en
pratique le temps ne serait pas le seul
et unique critère il serait possible le
pondéré de l'ajuster avec par exemple
les consommateurs les emplois et les
investissements mais le temps sera le
critère de base sur lesquels les états
se mettrait d'accord pour assurer une
répartition des richesses plus juste en
ce moment même la fiscalité est en train
d'être complètement repensé le g7 les
etats unis ont proposé avec succès un
taux d'imposition mondial de 15% pour
les multinationales
derrière ces débats
souvent politique
parfois technique il y a un enjeu
absolument cruciale c'est la répartition
des richesses dans le monde
je ne demande pas aux multinationales de
payer un centime de plus d'impôts ce que
je demande c'est de répartir les impôts
qu'elles paient de manière plus juste et
pour y arriver ce que je vous demande à
vous c'est un peu de votre temps pour
partager cette idée pour affirmer que le
temps de chaque personne dans chaque
pays a la même valeur et si on buvait
votre tasse de café vous demandiez
encore wallers
voici peut-être la réponse
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]